[Music]
all right thank you uh hello everybody
uh
and uh yeah i'd like to join marley and
other presenters in thanking
our studio uh and uh phil and and others
into putting the session together uh you
know this is my favorite community are
in pharma and i'm glad
to be here today and also thank you for
the opportunity to talk about
our uh in yongsan drug discovery
statistics
so my name is volya triputin and i work
as a principal statistician
in the department of translational
medicine and early
development statistics at janssen so
what do we do at janssen
well in yanson we are guided by our
mission
of blending heart science and ingenuity
to profoundly change the trajectory of
health for humanity
and we discover and develop drugs which
you know treat or are or lead to prevent
some of the world's devastating diseases
so how do we how do we discover and
develop drugs right well the process is
quite complex but it roughly can be
breaking down into two parts
pre-clinical drug discovery and
development efforts and clinical
and i think clinical uh drug discovery
uh drug development gets a lot of
spotlight
whether pre-clinical phase is not as
commonly talked about
so i'd like to take a couple of minutes
and to give you uh in a nutshell
what that really means uh to to discover
a drug right
so it all starts with uh with uh
choosing which disease you're after
right and then after you do that you
identify the target that you're gonna
try to pursue once you have that in
place
you trying to screen uh possible
compounds
or even engineer a new one they're gonna
bind to your target
and once that is done uh you basically
study
uh that that you know relationship or
that activity that is happening between
your compounds and target
uh and you might uh want to optimize it
and look at it at many many angles but
what happens at the end
you select a subset of compounds that
you're going to be
moving forward into other subset of
studies and once you have your subset of
compounds
you would further test them for efficacy
and safety
uh using uh in vitro which is outside of
your uh
you know living living body sort of
experiments
which could be testing those compounds
and tissue and cell lines
and then also in vivo experiments uh
where
you test your compounds in a living
organism
and then you know once uh that is done
you're basically ready to
move your final uh compound uh into uh
you know enemy phase which is uh naming
it for
a new molecular entity and that's sort
of complete your
pre-clinical uh drug discovery process
but as you can see
it's uh it's very very involved and uh
you know very very very
multifaceted so uh i work for uh
for drug discovery statistics group that
basically supports uh all of these
different
uh drug discovery efforts across
different uh therapeutic areas whether
it's
neuroscience oncology immunology
infectious diseases vaccines
and i would do a lot of work working
with a scientist so what our
department does it's obviously bringing
a mathematical and statistical rigor
into uh building this drug discovery
pipeline and also
for decision making right and so how do
we do it
well you know we take the body of data
a lot of uh studies that uh biologists
have conducted
and uh you know one of the aspects for
us is
obviously uh designing those studies and
uh work on
design of experiments but also the heavy
task for us
is to analyze all of the data right so
uh we put uh the data
into this uh sausage making machine
right called statistics
uh we add some magic to it and uh voila
we get a p
value right uh of course i'm joking it's
not as as
as you know as it is on the slide
but instead of magic we obviously have a
lot of math and statistics
uh within our sausage making machine
right and p-value
is uh one of the things but uh it's
never the only one
and we accompany all of our findings
with uh you know a lot of different
tables uh figures uh graphical
representation and
a lot a lot of different reports right
but where i'm trying to go with all of
this
is that you know we have this process in
place for analyzing this data
but what's uh really great is that uh
this whole process is driven by r
right uh in uh drug discovery statistics
department at janssen we heavily
rely on r and r studio products and this
is what my presentation is about
so how do we use our capabilities and
what do we do with r
in drug discovery statistics well the
most
important one is our portfolio support
so we use
r extensively to analyze a lot of our
studies
so when i was thinking how to best kind
of present what do we do with our i
thought about
splitting uh all the stuff that we do
into this four different spheres right
so first and foremost is our general
practices right
the majority of us uh use rstudio
and we do it uh we use it locally and uh
we
also use it off the server and the
server our studio capabilities are great
because what they
help us to do is share our projects
and our different study analysis uh
between ourselves within the group
and help us to collaborate in this in
this manner but also uh we've been
tapping lately in
in the powerful computing capabilities
of our studio server as well
for our analysis but also for shiny app
development
we all use git in bitbucket so bitbucket
is our local github we call it
which of course ensures traceability and
transparency of everything that we do
but also plays a big role in
collaboration and code sharing
we extensively use our packages so we
create our own whether they're internal
and external for of course organizing
our own code
but also for sharing our methodologies
with others
which of course speaks to the rigor and
innovation that our packages bring
to the whole drug discovery statistics
space
we also uh start packaging
our standardized analysis workflow that
we actually
use to create shiny apps into packages
as well
and that's again an easy way to share
your code
but also makes it easy to troubleshoot
or to bring
changes that might need to be
implemented if the opportunity comes
we also use our packages for
packaging basically templates for our
markdown which i'm going to
discuss next our markdown reports
something that we
simply can't survive these days so we
extensively use
uh our markdown reports for a lot of
stuff
i think in 2019 or maybe at the end of
that year
there was a big effort in a department
to create one
standardized parametrized our markdown
template
which kind of incorporates the set
expectation between ourselves
statistician of how we want to report
our statistics but also
between our you know clients our
biologist and whoever we work with
so what happens uh last year is we
decided to make
uh that parametrized general template
more specific to therapeutic area
uh that we work with uh for instance i
mainly support oncology so
we really customize that template that
we created first into oncology settings
which
is really cool because you know we can
customize it whenever we want it
but it also brings consistency to all
the analysis that we do within oncology
drug discovery space
and obviously speaks to reproducible
nature of our of our research
uh my favorite uh and everybody's
favorite are shiny apps
we do a lot of them we put them together
ourselves
and uh some of them you know for some of
them
we have our developers helping us as
well
when i was thinking how to present the
shiny apps i just would have you know we
can talk about them the whole day
uh but i basically put everything that
we do in terms of our shiny into three
buckets
so the first set of applications that we
develop for drug discovery
kind of goes into the bucket of data
manipulation
uh so that could be anything from you
know taking different data
files that scientists have coming from
different software that they're using
and putting them into shiny and you know
mapping the data
merging the files uh doing some other
pre-processing
and then basically exporting some other
data file type that they need the
scientists need to put into another
software or something like that right so
it could
could be an array of things that we can
do with with data which is
great that we can use shiny for that
because it really eliminates
uh any copy paste or editing error uh
and you know gives us so much confidence
that nothing like that has happened uh
while we're
pre-processing or manipulating our data
so once we have the data in the right
form of shape
the next thing that we do in statistics
is obviously take a closer look at the
data and we call it eda
so another set of shiny applications
that we have developed
kind of go into that bucket where they
have to do with data visualization and
exploration of your data which is super
important uh
and brain and efficiency in that space
kind of
talks to having a more thorough research
and obviously you know a richer about a
body of evidence
when it comes to data exploration and
then the last bucket
is uh basically apps that have to do
with a statistical analysis right and
here we've developed
a standardized uh workflows for a
particular analysis that scientists are
doing repeatedly
a lot of those apps have exportable our
markdown report whether it's pdf you
know word or html you name it
and this brings major efficiencies in
our space
because of automation of those repeated
tasks and analysis and report generation
and of course because of our studio
connect capabilities we can
easily deploy the apps and share them
with our colleagues
in in biology so you know four of these
things uh general practices our shiny
apps and our packages and our markdown
report uh
help us tremendously in a in a portfolio
development space
but what else we're doing with r well uh
i have the second
uh part aware which i call innovation
right so what i what do i mean by that
obviously this speaks a lot to open
source nature of
r that will all benefit uh from
and code sharing uh which
really facilitates uh not just within uh
within
department collaborations right but
collaboration across function
uh across companies with john johnson
and and even beyond going into the
community
so stat analysis automation uh
that that we're doing with shiny apps
and our markdown reports
really allow us to release a lot of
resources so we can go
and explore other cutting edge
technologies and bring innovative
solutions to
our drug discovery space now immediate
access to
all the art packages whether we're
creating our own
or using someone else's facilitates uh
innovative drug discovery statistics
solutions that we create uh in a in
our department and then something new
that johnson and johnson
haven't had before and had it in 2020
is jj hackathons that really
bring together a lot of different
employees from different parts of
johnson and johnson whether you're in
consumer or medical devices or pharma
to work on solving some of the uh very
interesting business problems
you know and i'm proud to say that
whoever participated in in that those
hackathons from
discovery discovery drug discovery
statistics are we're all
using r to solve those problems
so portfolio support innovation what
else right
training we've conducted a lot of
smaller trainings that have to do with
r but i want to concentrate on two
bigger ones
so the first one in graphics with r
which have been talked about uh in the
previous
uh you know years at the conferences at
iron pharma
and maybe others where uh statistics and
decision science
department at janssen put it together
and led it
with the aim of improving literacy in
our programming among
clinical statistician so it was
conducted to
more than 100 clinical statisticians
that went into the training
and it was presented by external art
experts and a lot of them came from
drug discovery statistics group which i
belong to
so what we've done we created a lot of
different homeworks
on different topics that cover gg plot
uh we started with youtube plot and it
was a major intention but
uh the appetite just grew and we had to
extend to our markdown interactive plot
study verse
uh dashboards and i think we ended up
with a small shiny app at the end
but we would deliver homework for for
people uh for
for trainees and then they would go into
review and regroup session and
brainstorm solutions
and then they would present the solution
on the general forum and discuss that
and then the expert would
sort of come with their tips and tricks
presentations
so it worked really well and it was in
2019
uh janssen so what happened last year
another great training i was was
designed and delivered and that was
led by quantitative sciences
organization and the aim there was to
promote
a shared foundation of quantitative
literacy in machine
learning space as a major major effort
was 25-week course again presented by
internal
internal expert those are statisticians
who have
advanced degree in machine learning
including again a colleague of mine and
myself
and mostly phd obviously who presented
content
about machine learning that was
structured in four different modules
about statistical learning
classification new supervised
unsupervised approaches
and was attended by hundreds of people
from all over
the company so that's going outside of
yansen even
and the way we we had it going was uh
you know discussion of the theoretical
part and then
a practical data application
and again i'm proud to say that for the
practical data application part we
use r entirely and we use our markdown
for all of our code we had a you know
standardized template the world used
and uh we basically delivered all the
solution in our markdown
and that sort of uh goes in uh the
representatories that a lot of trainees
or people who attended or who didn't
attend but want to learn
kind of can tap into into now
so we talked about portfolio support uh
innovation training
but i think r also helps uh to be to
build community whether it's 4r
or art driven uh so something that we
have going on
uh janssen and this is the stuff that uh
you know i'm uh
kind of involved and participating in
organizing
but maybe there are more uh is something
is
something like a shiny day that we've
been uh we've been having
for i think three last years which is an
uh annual event that is organized by
eons and quantitative sciences and
scientific computation um compute
computing operations uh in partnership
with the data and statistics society
which i colleed with some other people
where we basically bring our shiny
developers together
at one or two day event and you know
back in the pre-kobe time we would
actually
meet on site on different sites to kind
of get to know each
other and share some exciting work that
we're doing in shiny application
development space
uh but last year we had it obviously
remote
so that that has been of a great uh
interest and the community there is
growing
also within a gnga data and statistics
society we do have workshops
where we talk about our or you know
discuss some of the method developed in
r and uh you know the example there
could be
even having topics like uh using
different software but how do we plug in
our uh in those softwares and we had
something about tableau going on
and you know how to bring our
capabilities or how to connect r with
tableau and stuff like that
uh so we also have yammer internal
groups where our community is bubbling
and growing and i'm really
happy to be part of it and see it grow
and i think a separate community is
something that we have around internal
bitbucket or you know
internal github where people share code
and uh sort of create collaborations
something else that we all love is hex
stickers
so i i love those like everybody else in
this community
and i try to bring them uh in any effort
that i'm involved with
so some of the stickers that we've
developed are kind of go for our shiny
apps that we
created and uh you see an example of the
individual lda app
that i put together and you know have a
head sticker for it and then we put hex
stickers together
for uh different uh workshops or events
that we have you see a shiny day sticker
and then some of the workshop that we
had within that
and also we have a sticker for a
membership for data and statistics
society which were actually in quite
demand and we had to email them globally
which is
which is great so uh to summarize uh
our indians and drug discovery
statistics today and tomorrow
so i think today we heavily rely on r
and r studio products
we use our studio projects our markdown
reports shiny apps
are packages which bring efficiencies
and statistical rigor to our portfolio
they ensure reproducible and traceable
research and
also standardization and harmonization
of
methods workflows etc and
give us the capability of click quickly
adapt to changes
then open source nature of our provides
us
with immediate access an opportunity to
share
our cut and edge and state-of-the-art
statistical methodologies
and also facilitates innovation and
collaboration
and then we're growing our community
internally through different platforms
workshops internal events and trainings
and we're trying to give back to the
community by having our packages
on cran and presented at different
conferences
uh some notes for future potential i
think we can keep building a larger art
community
not just within our jansen
pharmaceutical space but also go into
other johnson johnson sectors whether
it's medical devices or
consumer finance etc so that's always a
great thing to do
i think there are ways to work on
sharing our code again across the
enterprise not just
within uh sub communities so i think
that would be something uh
great to do in the future and then
enhance and internal are packages
visibility this is something i also
feel is important and we can work better
there and with that i'm going to
conclude and say thank you to some
of my colleagues who helped me to
bounce back some of my ideas that i had
for this presentation and
uh once again thank you our studio and
people who organize
uh this iron pharma conference for
inviting me to speak
uh and uh here i'll conclude thank you
so much
[Music]